[Music]
welcome everyone to another episode of
LED live I'm Keith and today I'm joined
with a couple of guests we have Karen
and we have denitra who's been with us
before and of course we have denique one
of our team members and today we are
going to talk about boundaries maybe
some of you have had to set boundaries
in your life before well Karen is going
to help us realize setting boundaries is
a good thing from a unique angle one
that you may have never thought of
before so Karen tell us how did you get
into this concept of setting
boundaries well first of all um in my
earlier years I was a teacher in early
childhood education and uh how
early um ages zero 0 to five and then
also um kindergarten through second
grade mhm and so in that experience when
you're relating to children when you're
working with families and you have to
know how to set healthy boundaries but
still be loving and kind all the time
yeah absolutely so okay yeah and my
study of the
sanctuary um as the Lord was leading the
study of the sanctuary which is the
Tabernacle some of you are more familiar
with the Tabernacle back in the days of
Moses and how many of you are familiar
with Moses being on the
Mountaintop and he what did he receive
up there from God right Ten Commandments
The Ten Commandments and uh but then
Moses was there for a lot longer than
just a few days he was there for 40 days
and 40 nights right and the people were
freaking out down at the bottom of the
hill but he was busy he was up there
getting the plans for the Tabernacle
and the sanctuary that is so important
it was a place that they were going to
worship God and ultimately The Ten
Commandments uh was put into the most
holy place in the Ark of the Covenant
and you can see the Ark of the Covenant
there in that last room and inside that
Ark is where the Ten Commandments were
laid and kept safe yeah so he was also
fasting true the whole time 40 days and
40 nights
absolutely yes and so the study of the
sanctuary and of the um working with
children came together when I was
struggling with different behaviors that
the children were having and the Lord
was saying remember Moses and the time
when I brought Israel out that I gave
them love first and the law second so
before they came to the mountain God God
was rescuing them from Egypt in slavery
he was um taking them through the Red
Sea for deliverance and danger then he
fed them Mana from heaven and water from
The Rock he did all this nurturing to
build that relationship with his people
yeah and then they would were ready to
hear more about the laws which is kind
of the boundaries if you want to took
care of their physical needs yes yes and
emotional needs which what Jesus did
when he was born he took a pair of
people's needs yeah true true as a way
to minister to them and then he was
teaching them greater truths right
that's so true so true it's a
fascinating study I've I've looked at
that that section of scripture many
times and you look at the way that God
takes care of their their physical needs
and I see this you know when you combine
this with Hebrews chapter 3 and 4 this
big overarching theme God is essentially
telling them look if you can't trust me
with your physical needs to provide for
that how are you going to trust me with
your spiritual condition right that I
want to heal you from if you don't have
faith for this you won't have faith for
the other so it's kind of a fascinating
study but we're not here to talk about
that we're here to talk about boundaries
so yes absolutely but that's all
important because developing that trust
is the first stage of of emotional
development for children starting from
the womb and all the way to age three
you need to develop that trust and
meeting those children's needs in order
to win that love and respect and then be
able to set healthy boundaries and
they're with you then um and so what's
exciting is that the sanctuary and
Boundary setting go together uh in a
beautiful way because the sanctuary uh
that also became the temple Solomon's
Temple and it was exactly the same
design as what Moses has here um the
same exact design all the same Furniture
it was just twice the size yeah I made a
stone yes exactly that's right and and
made into a temple um this got weather
beaten over time and they wanted a
temple to worship God and the structure
of this sanctuary is extremely important
there are seven steps and we know seven
is an important number there are seven
steps in the sanctuary and the sanctuary
often when it is studied it's just
talked about in relationship to what
they did as uh the Hebrew people what
the priests did the furniture and all
those rights and rituals that happened
but really the sanctuary is has many
many different meanings and uh one of
them is that it was a prophecy of the
Salvation experience that we to have in
Christ all of these are prophetic for
Christ's Ministry to save
Mankind and there's so much in the
scriptures to support that y then there
is
also the understanding that the
sanctuary is all about
relationship and the first relationship
that we are to have in the sanctuary is
with God because each and with Jesus
because each one of the seven steps is
describing something special about
Jesus and something special of a way for
us to communicate and bond in a
relationship with Jesus it's not just
about furniture it's about bonding with
God because this is God's house amen
this is God's house what did Jesus say
when um he came to cleanse the temple
and he did it at the beginning and at
the end of his ministry he came and he
said this is my father's house of
prayer prayer you know okay yes we go
and pray in church and we know they came
and they prayed but literally each one
of these seven steps um are a special
way that we can pray Bond communicate
with Christ yeah and with the whole
godhead God the father and God the holy
spirit so it's just a powerful tool for
a relationship with God and also
relationship with each other that that
came later on in our study to see how
this model of bonding with Christ is a
model for bonding with each other amen
love thy neighbor as thyself and you
know love God with all your heart mind
and soul love your neighbor as yourself
absolutely absolutely so it's really um
really really awesome um I can share
just a a couple of texts uh one is in
Exodus 25:8 many people have this
memorized but just to show the purpose
of the sanctuary is
not uh just pieces of furniture and
rights and rituals of the priest it's
says then let them make a sanctuary for
me that I may dwell among them he this
reminds me of the verse um where jesus'
name was mentioned Emmanuel God With Us
absolutely and so like I don't know if
you we're going to go through what the
pieces of furniture mean but you know
obviously it's the door Jesus is the way
um it's the um Al of sacrifice where
they took the offerings the lamb that
was slain Jesus is the Lamb of God as
John the Baptist pointed out it's a
labor with the water there was baptism
which Jesus was also baptized and we
experience baptism it's a table of
showbread Jesus is um you know the word
right um and and it says that that Jesus
is the bread of life it's the um the
Candlestick where we we are supposed to
share the gospel um and that's the altar
of incense right prayer and then it's
the Ark of the Covenant where we find
the Ten Commandments we find the Aaron's
Rod that budded and we find Mana which
again represents the word of God and
that's where the shakina glory was where
God resided so everything points to
Jesus like you said and this is such a
deep study um by the way for the viewers
at home we have a podcast episode where
I talked extensively with Keith about
what the sanctuary means it's called
um what the Old Testament Tabernacle has
to do with your salvation we go in depth
into this so if you're interested look
up little light Studios podcasts
podcasts wherever you listen to your
podcasts um but yeah this everything
like you said points to Jesus and points
to how he wants to have a relationship
with us amen praise God that's perfect
yeah that's just exactly really like
that idea that you're bringing out the
relational aspect um when you look at
Exodus
25:8 you see God God's intention but
it's an intention that goes all the way
back to Genesis because sin separated
severed that relation between God and
man and so you see God as like okay let
me show you how I'm going to restore
that yes then you have John writing many
years later after live after having
lived with
Jesus and he says in John 1114 and the
word became flesh and dwelt Among Us and
of course the word there dwelt is John's
way of referring back to the Tabernacle
if you look at the language it's it's
it's similar even though he's you know
he's a Hebrew writer writing in Greek so
he's trying to bring out Hebrew ideas in
the Greek
language and of course the same writer
is reflecting back in Revelation 213
when he's writing about the consummation
of all things after God has accomplished
his purpose and restored that
relationship he uses the same language
because he says and I heard a loud voice
from Heaven saying behold the Tabernacle
of God is with men and he will dwell
with them and they shall be his people
God himself will be with them and be
their God so the relationship has been
restored and he's using that Sanctuary
language to describe all of that isn't
that beautiful that's beautiful text to
embellish what what we're studying what
we're learning in this dwelling that
Jesus wants to do in our hearts and us
to dwell with him and and and Dav David
talks about how he wants to come into
the sanctuary and dwell with God because
this is his house and Jesus is inviting
us to his home yes to dwell and how much
uh more can we minister to people if we
invite them to our house that's a that's
an important centerpiece in our lives
where we can Minister and nurture to
others and and this is how God wants to
do for us he has everything that we need
he has everything to do with salvation
is all inside this home right here and
so by uh understanding going be Beyond
just symbolism and finding the meaning
behind it he just like we teachers um we
like to have symbols to get the kids
attention but then we want them to grow
we want them to understand what's behind
all that symbolism and that's what Jesus
is doing that's why he made a
kindergarten copy of his home in heaven
this is the Heavenly Sanctuary this is a
kindergarten picture of the Heavenly
Sanctuary this is the throne room of God
the father is in the most holy Place God
the son is at the table of showbread
that's the sides of the north by the way
and then God the holy spirit is the
seven Branch candlesticks that's the the
spirit of God there and if you look at
it if you take the curtain out but leave
the altar of incense there you will see
a triangle
of the godhead and where are our prayers
coming right in the center with that
altar of incense which is the incense is
our prayers coming up and th that smoke
went over into the most holy place and
filled the whole room the whole godhead
is connected with us and they want to
connect uh us with them and to to
they're inviting us into their presence
into to their uh Most Holy place the
throne room and we can just look at at
Hebrews real quick for that invitation
where it says in Hebrews
4:14 to6 therefore since we have a great
high priest who has gone through the
heavens Jesus the son of God let us hold
firmly to the faith we professed because
we do not have a high priest who is
unable to sympathize with our weakness
but we have one who has been tempted in
every way just as we are yet was without
sin let us then approach the throne of
grace with confidence so that we may
find Mercy and find Grace to help us in
our time of need so he's inviting us all
the way to the most holy place to dwell
and bond with him there and he says come
boldly before the throne of grace and I
have everything you need in all the
texts previous to that in context in
Hebrews 3 and4 they're when you look at
the quotations they're all from Psalm 95
which is talking about that Wilderness
experience they had in Exodus
17 and essentially when you talk about
Exodus 17 you almost have to talk about
Exodus 16 because they're they're almost
identical events but they're just about
different things food and water and so
it's going back to that time of God
building that relationship leading up to
the sanctuary because they're about to
receive the Ten Commandments they're
about to start building the the
Tabernacle so it's all connected that
way amen beautiful absolutely and um and
you may be wondering you know how does
this have to do with boundaries but just
looking at this Sanctuary do you see
boundaries already set up everywhere and
then then in the temple and um there are
boundaries that are all set up rooms
compartments and places that we dwell
and bond with God there and so it's
important to um be able to understand
what each compartment represents and how
we're bonding with God and then how to
bond with other people um in this way
and so I think that I would like to take
a look at the fact that God wants us and
this is where this transition happened
for me is that we are temples as well
and God wants us to know how to not only
come and dwell in his Temple but how to
have him dwell in our Temple and he
wants to cleanse our soul Temple he
wants to cleanse our soul Temple um and
he has the power to do that he created
us as a reflection a small little
reflection of him and so as we cooperate
in this bonding experience and in this
prayer experience in the sanctuary he
can use all these steps to cleanse us
and cleanse our Temple of any Idols or
anything that's not like him and this is
um the court holy and most holy place
are the compartments there and that each
one of them gets us into a closer walk
with him and you think about holy most
holy and um and and Ellen White says
that Holiness is agreement
with God so as we get more in uh in
agreement with him as we get closer to
him we get in agreement with what he's
thinking and feeling that is going to
cleanse our soul Temple of our own
thoughts and feelings with the mind of
Christ so that we're in Oneness and
harmony with Christ as we dwell in this
Sanctuary with him and I think that it
also takes people off of a pedestal that
we put them in um it puts God in the
position in every area of Our Lives that
he's supposed to be in you know I know
being a woman sometimes you can put men
in a certain position emotionally where
they shouldn't be too soon uh in your
heart and I think create you know having
these boundaries and really going
through this process of emotional and
mental healing puts people exactly where
they're supposed to be and they stay
there and uh and it's just such a
beautiful thing because God created us
to be able to minister to other people
but but it gets so convoluted when we're
not healed and we end up giving too much
too soon when we're not supposed to and
God created us to have a balanced mind
and so when we go through this whole
process of emotional healing and
learning how to put people where they're
supposed to be it can be balanced and
you can be able to minister to people
but not give too much yes and it's just
a beautiful thing
absolutely there's is an interesting
concept too was talking about boundaries
and we haven't even got there yet
but God sets boundaries based on
circumstances you
know often times in our in in response
to our relationship with him so when
Adam and Eve had to leave the Garden of
Eden it was a boundary that had to be
set like look I have to separate now the
clean from the unclean the holy from the
Unholy yeah same thing at Mount Si right
he's like look you can't you can only
come so far that's otherwise it will
result in your death same thing with
just the ark who was able to transport
it only the priest right one Israelite
makes a mistake thinking not that big a
deal but it was God had set boundaries
in place and I don't know if you're
going to get to this but there's another
boundary in this system you you don't
see mhm and that's beyond the walls of
this of the sanctuary mhm you have a big
open space all the way around true yeah
that's true I like that and nobody is uh
approaching that unless it
is the time and place for it in other
words they're keeping their
distance until it's time and that time
was you know for most of the people when
they sin now they're bringing a lamb to
the temple everybody can see them from
way off and there since there's nothing
in the middle it's easy to spot somebody
and be like imagine the personal
humiliation that's now going on because
here you are lamb and toe and everybody
can look at you because now you're
you're entering into that space that
space acts as a boundary because they
camped all the way around yeah and there
was nothing in between so even though
there wasn't a wall
there was still a boundary I love that
very interesting I love it that I am so
glad you said that I have not thought
about that and that goes along with our
um invisible boundaries that we have
around our body you know where bubble
yes I was to say the same
thing exactly and we don't you know
we're not supposed to kind of cross over
into that invisible boundary and we we
know not to to go too close to people I
mean that's just kind of built in but
then people do violate the that unseen
surrounding of the temple that we have
that's it's relationally understood you
know it's like denitra came today and we
hugged we didn't do that the first time
we met I don't think and I shook her
hand but happens over time right and
it's the same with we get closer and
closer to God you know that that bonding
there's certain people it's like you
know it's like that's my wife
absolutely you stay away right right
exactly right so and you know the same
for for women like that's my husband you
stay away right yes right because those
boundaries are are reserved for only
certain people yes exactly exactly and
that takes me back to what you were
saying denitra where in the most holy
place all of us have a most holy place
that that is the throne room where God
is and we're not supposed to have any
other other gods before him he is to
take the Throne of our hearts completely
and so um then other people now and in
the sanctuary here in the courtyard
that's where all the people were allowed
to come in they were allowed to come in
to worship um and but who were the only
ones that were allowed to go into the
holy Place priests priest only the
priests were allowed to come word chosen
from the levit yeah and so the this
Sanctuary not only in our relationship
with God but with with each other is
about intimacy and there are levels of
intimacy that we have with people and
we're allowed to set boundaries where
these people are depending on their
behaviors how they handle I mean um
whether they do things in the in the
proper way or not we have a right to set
boundaries and I think I'll look at this
next one when we see um the court holy
and most holy place and then all the
pieces and they all mean so much I'm
glad you have a study I also have a
study uh on my website about the
different steps and bonding with Christ
in each one of those steps what's that
website um Sanctuary forf families.com
oh awesome yes I want to check that out
yes she has a 21 part wasn't it 21
videos that's so cool very extensive so
I've done those that's that study and it
and it's the number four by the way
because and I'll tell you why it's the
number four there are so many once I did
this I didn't realize there are so many
websites Sanctuary for families because
it means a safe place and I do a study
on it being the sanctuary means safety a
bird sanctuary an animal sanctuary it's
a safe place God is calling us to run to
the sanctuary for safety and so that we
those websites are all about sanctuaries
for um children who might be abused of
uh domestic violence and these are
Sanctuary for families so but here's the
ultimate Sanctuary for all of us and for
our families and uh it is a safe place
and we do have um a number of verses
that talk about that I I just want to
read just one really quick since we're
talking about safety for just a moment
that this is the Arc of the Covenant
there is the Ark of Safety for God's
people in the last days this is going to
be the little Ark that we have that
spiritually we're going to be bonded
with Christ in Christ with Heavenly
surrounding us um safe inside this Ark
just like Noah's Ark of old and we can
and we're in times today where there is
fear on every side and we need a safe
place to hide in Christ and there are
many
um verses but we'll just use this one
here Psalms 61 verse4 real short one I
long to dwell in your tent forever and
take refuge in the shelter of your wings
where's this Sheltering
Wings you know this this reminds me of
uh the Bible verse that says um God is a
strong tower we run in and we are safe
um you thinking about you're were saying
about safety in the sanctuary in Bible
times there used to be something called
Sanctuary cities right so if if you had
committed
manslaughter so someone had died without
you intentionally killing them I don't
know maybe your cow kicked him and he
died or something
you could run to a sanctuary city right
and then get Fair trial instead of the
family coming in just taking your life
the family of the victim um and this
makes me think of we are all sinners
yeah we are all uh guilty of murdering
the Son of God right because we have
sinned this our sins were what uh made
him die on the cross and we we are only
safe when we come into His Sanctuary
right when we come just like they ran to
the sanctuary cities we have to run to
Jesus to the sanctuary where God dwells
where Jesus is ministering to save our
lives abut and then just going through
that whole cleansing process when you're
talking about a fair trial that is what
happens in the sanctuary when you're
dwelling with the Lord he walks you
through these things in your life that
don't agree with him and you walk
through it together you know um and it's
it's it's a beautiful thing it's a
beautiful Harmony uh even when he is
bringing up things that are things you
may have said things you may have done
um things you may have thought you know
um that don't align with him it's not a
bashing it's not a criticism it's not
negative it's all love it's fascinating
you look at the words you know Sanctuary
sanctification similar right Sanctuary
being a safe place yes sanctification
process of making one holy or should we
say safe right oh I like that I really
like implication we're not safe in our
current sinful condition not at all we
are dangerous mm if you will right or we
have the ability to cause harm to others
yeah and so God is making us safe that's
amen I love that
that is beautiful beautiful he uh we are
to be um he doesn't want to take you
know kind of like quarantined here we
deal with the sin problem here he
doesn't want to take remnants of that
back into heaven where those roots will
spring up again he wants us to work it
through come into harmony with him here
in his Sanctuary so that we are at
onement with him we are in agreement
with him in everything which is Holiness
and he can work us walk us through it
step by step as we listen to his voice
in each one of these seven compartments
it's so beautiful and uh so one of the
first ones that is um the mo this first
step is I don't know in some ways the
most important and a lot of times we
skip it we miss it but it is so so key
because um Isaiah 28 talks about there's
a battle at the gate there's a battle at
the gate because there's an enemy and we
want to get into this safe place into uh
God's presence and how do we get into
that it's through the gates of praise
and how do we know about that Psalm 100
exactly Psalm 100 verse four the
Thanksgiving Psalm yes and there's only
five verses um it's short but powerful
and I'll just read uh verse four that
says enter his gates with than
Thanksgiving and his courts with praise
give thanks to him and praise His name
and we know that this is easy to do like
in church a lot of times or even when we
first wake up but it's very difficult to
stay in Praise all day because the enemy
is bashing us Satan who's outside the
gate means accuser yeah accuser of the
Brethren um is what he does all day long
and so one of the key things about
knowing how to stay in communication
with Christ and stay bonded with him is
to know that he is positive about
everything and the devil is negative
about everything anything negative is
not from God all things positive he he
is the gay he says I am the gate I am
the door and that means that he is
praising he is giving us love not only
are we giving him praise but he is
giving us uh thankfulness he's thankful
for us he is giving us love and
affirmation and encouragement all the
time and we need to connect with that
and run in away from the enemy and that
is outside the gate and stay connected
with Christ and where the the devil
really gets Christians is with guilt and
we think guilt is from from God but
guilt and condemnation are all from
Satan and that's outside the gate we
praise him first we get into that love
relationship with him first and then
step number two is the altar of
sacrifice where the the lamb was slain
it looks like a you know a a cow there
to be slain on the altar of sacrifice
representing Jesus death there is where
we have um a spirit of confession and
repentance but we're not and and he does
convict us of sin convict us of things
that are wrong in our life but it is
never in a negative way when it's with
Christ there's always hope there is a
willingness on our part to to just lay
it down and let it go and he just wants
us to take take uh he wants to be able
to take that sin and bond with us he
says I was weeping for you on the cross
I shed my blood with love not with
condemnation I was shedding with
acceptance and wanting to make that path
so we could bond it's none of it is
shame blame condemnation that's all from
the devil everything stays positive with
Christ I think we've talked about this
before um there's a book that is used
for people who are dealing with
depression and anxiety it's called
telling yourself the truth you familiar
with that one I am familiar with it and
it goes right along with what you're
saying is and some people are more
guilty of this than others they tell
themselves
lies and so the idea is where do those
Lies come from right they come from the
enemy and so in order to recalibrate the
mind if you will you have to use God's
word as the ultimate source of Truth so
that the mind is always standing in the
truth and not in the lies of the enemy
and I think another another big thing in
addition to the guilt and the
condemnation is the the criticism and
the criticism I I know I have a history
of criticism I easily can why she do
that I don't understand why he did that
and why she did that I'm always in my
mind trying to figure out why somebody
did something sure and um there you know
when you're talking about the gates of
praise and that there's a battle at the
gate what does that really mean that
battle is facing those critical thoughts
headon and what I do when I start to um
dwell on a critical thought too long if
it's something that just okay came in my
mind twice I may not pay no attention to
it but then it's it's to three times I'm
thinking about the same thing wondering
why somebody has done something I start
I start giving it back to the Lord Lord
please Lord why tell me first I'm asking
him why why am I thinking like this why
am I thinking about this then I start to
just go into this battle prayer with the
Lord back and forth about it working
this thing through until it's gone and
that that that's really overcoming that
criticism because if we keep dwelling on
those things not only are is it is it
affecting us and our mind but it's
affecting how we treat the other person
absolutely absolutely and that's why
this is not only um our relationship
with Christ and letting go in in of
those negative thoughts that all come
from Satan and uh he's the father of
lies and so all of the lies are negative
and all truth is positive and Jesus says
I am the way thy way oh God Sanctuary
the truth M which is like the holy
places the truth yes and then and the
life which is the most holy place um and
and he wants to lead us into that life
and back to truth we have uh in this
whole boundary setting figuring out what
the truth is is so important to be able
to stand your ground and we'll be
talking about that in the future um and
that rock Jesus Christ is you could put
the word truth on that rock and in order
to set boundaries we need to know what
the truth is so we can stand on it and
not be blown by the storm and um but not
go into negativity either and we uh will
be talking about those things as we go
along and in applying these things but
these first two steps especially are so
important for us to understand how to
bond with Christ and now we're going to
bond with other people in those same
ways because they're a temple I'm a
temple
um Etc uh what we need to do I think is
share a couple of texts really quick and
then um about how we are a temple and
then show how we can go into each
other's Temple through that gate of
praise it says do you not know that your
body is the Temple of the Holy Spirit
the holy spirit is there at the seven
Branch Candlestick who is in you whom
you have received from God you are not
your own you were bought with at a price
therefore honor God with your body
flipping back a page to 1 Corinthians 3
verse 16 and 17 do you not know that you
yourselves are God's Temple and that
God's spirit lives in you if anyone
destroys God's Temple God will destroy
him he's going to set a boundary by the
way on anybody who's trying to destroy
us um for God's Temple is sacred and you
are that Temple so we can feel with
confidence as we go forward to
understand these principles of
communication and bonding that they
apply in our lives as well so if we want
to go into somebody else's Temple or we
need to set a boundary on someone coming
into our Temple what is the main uh
principle then that we need to follow
and we can look at John chapter
10 where Jesus talks about um coming in
through the door coming in through the
gate uh and 10 verse one says I tell you
the truth the man who does not enter the
Sheep pen by the gate but climbs in some
other way is a thief and a
robber okay so there's only one way in
which he later clarifies who that Thief
is in John
10:10 you know by saying Satan is the
one who's the thief that comes to steal
and to kill and destroy so you know he
didn't come in by the gate no by
implication of his statement absolutely
absolutely that's perfect and and so we
um we are not going to let other people
or the devil come in to that into our
Sanctuary by some other way so the right
way to come is with praise positive
Thanksgiving now we don't necessarily
maybe praise people but we need to be
able to affirm them we need to be able
to say the positive things in in their
lives when we see them um it's hard to
do that we're in We're In the Heat of a
battle and we're already in an argument
but once you learn these principles um
you can escort quickly people out onto
the porch and that are way inside your
Sanctuary inside your temple we escort
them out onto the porch they don't know
because what is the porch right there at
the gate we're going to be saying
positive things about those other people
and um and that's going to be hard to do
but we're going to stop arguing and and
and trying to make our point trying to
defend yourself yes exactly and we're
just going to stop and put the other
first person first put the other person
first and um say something positive say
something that shows that you are
listening to them that you are hearing
them and going to start with positive
things about what they're saying if
we're a temple what does that look like
uh the courtyard is
behaviors thoughts and feelings is the
holy place and the motives our motives
are in the most holy place now I'm going
to show it on this again here um look
how it can be our body and I love now
that not only is it a body but it's that
atmosphere around that you spoke of that
there is this atmosphere around our body
that's a boundary as well and then our
spirit we have the Holy Spirit in the
Holy place and then our spirit and our
mind uh we've got the mind of Christ at
the table of showbread um as well and
then the Deep inner soul our soul is in
um which is almost like
our um spiritual DNA of who we are in
the most holy place and so this uh can
take a little while to to flesh out a
little bit but just so that you know
that here we can stay on the porch with
people we need to stay there until they
are in a mode of positivity to Come Into
My Sanctuary but I am to stay positive
with their Sanctuary because I'm on
their porch too and so I need to stay
positive with them now what we've
discovered is that when we are sharing
our thoughts and our
feelings then um we are actually opening
the gates wide for people to rush into
our holy place when we are trying to
break down all the thoughts that we have
all the feelings that we have in order
to try to force the other person to come
into agreement with us when they are not
in agreement I thought about this before
I mean obviously this happens very
frequently with people in dating
relationships right like they just go
really fast like I tell you everything
and a whole story and and then we can
why do they want to do that because they
want to create a very quick connection
they want to have that but you see it
too with people who are maybe not in a
dating relationship but are maybe still
growing in the emotional health and
maturity who just tend to tell you
their whole story and I thought about
that why would people like that do that
and I think it's probably has to do with
the same thing of wanting to have maybe
an affirmation a connection and to know
like I'm accepted I'm okay to have the
closer bond to feel I mean maybe they
just haven't had that in their life and
they want that that desire that but
really if you think about it God's way
is to take like through the sanctuary is
to take the steps right small steps
where if you do that whether it's dating
whether it's in any other way any other
friendship or whoever you know there's
so much more depth in that there's so
much more Beauty in that and like I said
there's boundaries you're protecting
yourselves from those people who might
take advantage of you as you completely
lay yourself bare um they might take
advantage of you if you do that but if
you just kind of like f it out you know
and just say no you stay you stay over
there in the in at the gate and then see
are they trustworthy they have to prove
themselves trustworthy and then you come
in um and it's the same with our
relationship with God God is saying I
will prove myself trustworthy to you um
and and then you know you want to come
in closer yes absolutely sounds like
you're saying I shouldn't live every
detail of my life on social media no
pretty much right and then there's that
yeah but you know it and it goes back
back to putting people where they should
not be you know um when we don't have a
deep relationship with God and we don't
really know how to get that um we're all
longing for something he he put that
desire in everyone and it's so much
easier because you know Jesus isn't like
sitting right by you you can't like give
Jesus a hug and so it's easy it seems
much more tangible to connect with a
person because a person is physically
there but when we understand the concept
of how to attach to God and understand
that his holy spirit dwelleth inside of
us and he is more emotionally there than
anybody will ever be when you really get
that Concept in your mind and it dwells
into the inner depths of your mind and I
I'm I'm just saying it because it I mean
it had to really you got to really
connect with it then you you learn to
you want to P not put push people away
in unhealthy way but you don't want
people to come too close because you
understand that there's nobody in this
world I don't care how my my sisters I I
don't care how fine he is how good he
smells how many wonderful things he has
to say there's no one in this world that
can meet your needs mhm you know um only
he can do that but when we are not when
we don't understand that and we want to
feel somebody instead of feel really
what we're really looking for is to feel
the love of Jesus but we're trying to
replace that with a person y uh you
start just pouring yourself out
everywhere yep an open book yeah
absolutely absolutely and um if we look
at these sanctu this the sanctuary now
is a place for intimacy it's a place for
bonding and Oneness and agreement yeah
that they this is only where there's
supposed to be agreement and when two
people are in agreement then almost our
sanctuaries overlap and we can share our
thoughts and feelings freely with one
another levels of intimacy getting
deeper and deeper just like a house you
know we have that porch we let people in
the door there may be the old-fashioned
parlor you know where the courtyard
reminds me of the Parlor where you can
you know visit back and forth you wait
until things develop you share U more
surface things with the other people and
develop that intimacy of trust and
positivity if there's any negtive ity
they're back on the porch again we are
not going to be intimate at that moment
when we're in disagreement with one
another now we are still going to stay
positive and we are uh going to walk
still walk with that person we're not
abandoning them but we're we're not uh
going to overlap into this type of
intimacy that is unhealthy we're going
to reserve our inner thoughts and
feelings between us and God or others
that we are in agreement with yeah
boundaries is for when we are in
disagreement when um we don't need a
boundary so much if we're in agreement
with each other there's not as much of
that need in in an argument for example
yes we still need boundaries for levels
of intimacy with one another um but we
need to to be monitoring where people
are in our house you know like I say the
The Parlor then you've got the living
room where there's a deeper relationship
with that person and then you have the
the bedroom which is like the most holy
place and husband and wife are to be one
you know in in so many ways um and
there's that Oneness and we're supposed
to be at onement with God in that most
holy place but be aware of those levels
and that the temple has all kinds of
boundaries set in emotionally so that
God can keep us safe and protected
emotionally as we are sharing
um information with other people you
know I was thinking of uh like you were
saying the bedroom usually when somebody
comes over to your house if you have a
your whole place is on one floor you
keep the bedroom door closed you don't
just go have visitors like oh yeah and
they just look into your bedroom like
for some reason at least in American
Western culture you don't show that um
and you especially don't just show them
your your upper floor if you have a
multifloor house um and I was thinking
about that with uh marriage you know
like the M the marriage bed is is like
only for you and your
spouse and so there's also specific
conversations like you're it's talking
about here about emotions in the most
holy place there are specific
conversations specific things you share
that you do not share with uh the
opposite sex if it's not your spouse
yeah absolutely you know my husband and
I are very strict with that and we
openly communicate
hey so and so sent me a message if if if
if some lady sends him a message
regarding something completely it
doesn't matter like hey uh you know um
what are he bringing to potl yeah
exactly I'm like he he he tells me and
I'm like you don't have to tell me that
that's fine but as soon as somebody
reaches out to him as soon as someone
reaches out to me with a longer text
more explanation maybe they're talk
about their feelings we communicate with
each other and we try to be polite to
those people but wrap it up I've once
had
someone appro talked to me multiple
times about their emotions to the point
where I had a conversation with this
person saying look I I'm was I was
engaged so at the time I'm engaged I
prefer not to have these kind of
conversations I believe it's better to
be rude to that person than to let them
into my emotional Sanctuary that I share
with God and with my spouse only yes
amen absolutely that's perfect
absolutely perfect and that reminds me
of the children because when we talk
about the kids um and the room you know
I mean you know I'm not trying to judge
nobody but sometimes we be having them
babies up in that bed for way too long y
you know and so the kids tend to uh
infiltrate on that personal space that
really is only designated for the
husband and the wife and not only are
they you know it's a sign that they are
coming that that they are being put
first in the relationship when they are
spending too much time in the bedroom MH
yes yes absolutely that's so true and
God wants us to feel comfortable in
setting those boundaries and that kind
of transitions me to another topic that
is going to be expanded more I'm sure uh
more in the future but that it is
important that we figure out what the
truth is and put it over into a left
brain logical statement of Truth to the
other person you did it so
perfectly um it was not an attack on
that other person it was not describing
all the thoughts and feelings that go
with that and and sometimes and those
who are more verbal and emotional might
want to end up sharing all the reasons
why this boundary is necessary and all
the the hurtful things that are caused
by it and on and on we've just opened
the door and let that person deep into
our holy place where we're sharing all
the reasons why we think and feel but we
need to go out with just these oneliner
statements yeah that put it into a
logical oneline truthful statement fact
that's not an attack on the other person
but just saying I don't feel
comfortable um communicating like this
I'm reserving that for my spouse that's
just two sentences I always tell my
clients because they all say well well
can I say I'm setting a boundary you you
don't have to tell the person that you
are setting a boundary you don't have to
say I'm setting a boundary the boundary
is for you you're you're just making it
clear that there's a boundary it's
almost like you're creating an invisible
line you know but you don't have to tell
them that this is my boundary you know
sometimes we feel better when we say
that um but it's really for it's more
for you than it is for the other person
the other person follows suit as a
result of you setting the boundaries mhm
absolutely that's right and then um when
we're describing to the other person in
just a one or two sentences um it it's
just it's about what I believe is true
and we can stand on the rock of that
truth and though the heavens fall we can
stand on that truth and we do not have
to explain away all the reasons why
we're doing that because that's going to
make us fall down into an argument
because then they're going to try to
prove you wrong and explain why it's not
really that way this can happen with
teenagers a lot you know when with
parents and teenagers relationships and
they're going back and forth in the mud
about it when they could get up on the
Rock and just say um I don't feel
comfortable uh with this that or the
other and and we can State a reason one
reason and just leave it at that and um
not get pulled
into trying to make the other person and
this is another whole topic that we'll
go into uh soon which is an um trying to
make the other person come into
agreement with us with our logic by
defending ourselves and trying to
explain because what we really want them
to do is to agree with why we're setting
the boundary like we can't be in
disagreement with the other person
that's painful to be in disagreement
with the other person so we're going to
try to force them to come into agreement
with us that this boundary is important
and needed so that they will keep it
rather than me and God are going to
stand on the rock of Truth and God's
going to help me keep it I don't need
that other person to agree with this
boundary that it's valuable that it's
important that it's anything that's um
that's where that boundary stands right
there so that's a that's another
important principle to keep in mind
as um we are interacting with other
people yeah it just reminds me of
looking at the Body Spirit Soul Court
holy Place Most Holy place it just
reminds me of the male female the
courtship engagement in marriage and how
the Lord is taking us through that same
process as he's wooing us back to him
you know we're getting to know him we're
getting to understand his behaviors how
he treats other people being outward
focused
affirmation then we're coming into
Oneness with his Spirit lies versus the
truth learning how to hear his to
understand his word process his word um
and then you know praying for others
praying to him giving him our deepest
thoughts and then you know the the holy
Place Most Holy Place really coming into
full agreement with him which is which
is marriage yes I think it's Amos 33
that says can two walk together except
they be agreed yes yes you know
implication is if you're not you're not
walking together exactly exactly and we
need to allow those relationships you
know instead of over overlapping our
sanctuaries that if we're not in
agreement right now we can be here
instead of overlapping it doesn't mean
it can even be our spouse it doesn't
mean we're bonded in one with that
person but we don't agree on this issue
then we can just be separate on that
it's okay we don't have to be in
agreement but we are driven for that
that's the the um the deeper motives
here in the most holy place is um that
we are driven to have people come into
agreement with us but here at the altar
of sacrifices where we also are going to
be um humble and self-sacrificing to the
other person as we are willing to listen
to their point of view that is not in
agreement with my point of view we want
to be willing to hear them out before we
bombard them and try to get them to
force them to come into agreement with
us and we're listening only to argue our
point and think of the next statement
but this this this is you know instead
we're listening with an an open heart to
understand that other person to know
where they're coming from um and then a
as if there is agreement that begins to
happen as we
communicate um at the water of the
word supposed to be word um those Waters
uh it says in Ephesians 5 it says that
God Jesus wants to wash us with the
water of the word which is communication
that we have with God and we have
communication with each other as well
and
so we can communicate with them to see
if uh agreement can happen but if not
then we have to set the boundary of what
we will or will not do and continue to
stay on the porch or at the gates with
affirming them while staying on the rock
of truth about what we can and cannot do
if we come into agreement or we agree to
disagree we can say well I can get your
point I can see how you are and I'm okay
with you feeling that way or that way
this way especially in those more
intimate uh marriage type relationships
uh we can agree to disagree and still
commune with one another even though we
have different opinions um and that
intimacy can grow greater as we come
into Oneness of spirit with one another
at step four and then we can not only Su
with Christ but we Su one with another
as we communicate deeper to understand I
wonder why this person feels this way I
wonder why they're coming from this
angle and we're not so busy talking
talking talking but we're in a listening
mode putting the other person first so
that we can understand and communicate
with one another more clearly and um
then as we come into Oneness greater and
greater Oneness we can be more and more
outward focused and Ministry focused on
other people uh as a couple or um as
friends you it could be um you know a
girlfriend or guys that are hanging out
together you can actually do more
Ministry for other people and be outward
focused and be a blessing and uh then
the final step of at onement is is where
there's complete unity and Oneness um
which is not normally the case uh with
most people there's only a few uh that
can come but they should never take the
place of God who sits on the throne and
so this is all about intimacy and
Oneness here when we're connecting
deeply but if this person is in
disagreement then we don't have to feel
pushed to make them come in agreement we
can feel that it comfortable with them
being out on the porch and just
ministering to them and maintaining
those oneliner boundaries about what we
feel comfortable with in our Temple I
think that a lot of the reason why we're
not able to uh fully carry this out is
because of fear um fear of like you said
being in dis I just remember you know my
inability to get along with people in
relationships and always in some sort of
argument with something someone um and
and a lot of it was this impulsivity
feeling like I had to say what I had to
say and uh not really ever being able to
listen with the intention of really
wanting to understand where is this
person coming from what are they really
trying to say and a lot of it was rooted
in fear mhm you know fear that of of
Abandonment fear of rejection uh fear um
of being hurt uh fear of what that
person was going to say uh how they
would react what they would think of me
so once the Lord really started to work
in my heart in a deep way to overcome
these fears that came from childhood cuz
because a lot of it all of it came from
there um and really started to break
those things down for me and help me to
heal from those things now being able to
listen listen to people it's it doesn't
feel um it was a I had to restrain
myself to listen to people I had to it
had to be an intention I had to really
be intentional about it um but now it's
it's it's simple you know it God makes
things so simple but it's the fear and
the emotional pain that gets it so
convoluted and makes it seem so
difficult um but it's very simple once
we come into agreement with him we will
freely be able to come into agreement
with others so the key is learning to
come into agreement with him yes
otherwise none of this works very good
denitra um as you can see on this screen
we have on this deepest levels the
motives where our emotional Roots come
from and how in childhood is where all
these emotional Roots begin where the
roots start
but at the beginning of our lives and so
at the beginning of our Lives is where
these roots are we have good roots
praise God but we do have roots of
bitterness because we were not all um
listened to heard affirmed and
understood which all has to do with
being in agreement and so there was
disagreement between us and our parents
and we had to just leave it like that
trauma leaves us feeling rejected and uh
abandoned and disconnected from our
parents so now uh we can be triggered in
a present situation where these roots
from childhood now there's a
disagreement again we feel disconnected
from this person we feel abandonment now
and we feel this um very strong drive to
force the other person to come into
agreement so that we can be one again
that we can be understood we can be
heard but the other person needs the
same thing so once we get connected with
Christ yeah and get his um Assurance
about what the truth is about us and we
get more and more healing on those roots
and we feel that Oneness in Christ and
we feel covered with his robe of
righteousness with his full armor of God
the the helmet of salvation that says I
love you I'm I've got you don't worry
don't worry then we can stop we're all
protected and covered in our Sanctuary
we can you know escort that person in
our emotional uh Sanctuary out to the
porch and just listen now because
they're being triggered too they are if
you're in an argument it's because they
it's life and death for them to push you
to come into agreement with them yeah if
it's we can always go to their feelings
and second witness their feelings and
say that must have been very hurtful I'm
I I can see that um was difficult even
if it's something that we may have done
that we didn't mean to do and we want to
explain ourselves but if we stop and
just say that must have been a very
difficult thing for you we're addressing
their hurtful emotions we can always
agree that they were probably hurt or
that this is very concerning to them
yeah and and and come into Oneness now
we're in agreement again but we're doing
it for them rather than forcing them to
do it for us we've already got God we
don't need to have that make that person
come into AG greeness agreement so that
there is Oneness and unity Even in our
empathy for that other person amen
sounds like whenever
we um are
insecure then we tend to
manipulate yeah and I don't know if
you've experienced that in counseling
with people but well I mean I've
experienced it doing it myself you know
just
just um trying to get my needs met it's
it's a it's a counterfeit to the
sanctuary we do the exact opposite where
instead of surrendering Our lives our
thoughts our feelings our beliefs
whatever it is we're thinking
surrendering that being willing to lay
that down just to listen to the with and
and most of the time when you take the
time to do that you'll end up realizing
that what you thought the person thought
and what you thought the person was
saying is not at all what you thought
they were saying so you end up getting
clarity about the whole situation when
you're really willing to listen to what
somebody has to say so it gives you
Clarity but see Satan is the confu he's
the the the uh he's the the author of
confusion he does not want any Clarity
he doesn't want anybody to be validated
he doesn't want anything to be clear he
wants nothing but confusion and so it's
the exact opposite it's trying to do
whatever you
can
subconsciously just to focus on yourself
and
inadvertently by doing that um you're
not able to come into agreement with
each other it you know then there comes
manipulation then there comes um
self-seeking then there comes um you
know uh impulsivity you know compul
compulsions you know some of these
things are not necessarily intentional
they're just the result result of our
inability to be willing to lay our
thoughts down and ourself down to listen
it's reminds me of the verse love casts
out fear there you go right so like if
the root of this behavior is anxiety and
fear insecurity then really the solution
is Jesus yes and it's God's love right
which brings us back to the sanctuary
right right absolutely and the Bible
says that love covers a multitude of
sins so if we're connected with Jesus
love
for us and we're already secure in that
now we can cover the other person in
love and it will deescalate the whole
situation we can always share our
opinions later yeah when it's the right
time but we need that person to feel
safe and loved as well or be willing to
never share your opinion at all you know
what I'm saying like sometimes we have
to be willing that you may not ever the
person may not ever know what you really
think and is that okay are we willing to
do that for some for someone else just
so that they could be heard you know um
and it's hard to do when you're not
walking in Christ I I don't think you
can't do it you can do it on the surface
sure um but to truly do it with um the
love of God it's not it's not doable
because he he's the one who created us
to be able to do it so amen well thank
you ladies for sharing about boundaries
and if you find yourself as being one of
those
insecure persons maybe I think all of us
experience insecurity at some level know
that you can find security in Christ I
think through all of this the thread is
come to Jesus Jesus can heal you you
know physically mentally emotionally you
know and and heal your
relationships and so thank you for
sharing thank you for sharing your
wisdom and for those of you that are
watching thank you for watching make
sure you give this video a thumbs up
make sure you uh comment you know share
your experience down below you don't
have to go into great detail but maybe
you can say you know I was hurt once
upon a time and I learned you know
applying some similar principles how to
have healing myself make sure that you
subscribe to our channel so that you can
get notified about videos like this also
if you want to help us out you can go to
ls. we're also on patreon and we have
some pretty cool merch like the
sweatshirt that I'm wearing you can go
to lightwear do shop and get get some
Christian t-shirts and wear your witness
other than that we will see you next
time thank you for joining us do you
have questions about the Bible that
you've been struggling to find the
answers for video Bible study or VBS for
short is a YouTube channel that answers
your Bible questions in 5 minutes or
less check out these easy to understand
comprehensive videos talking about
everything from what happens when you
die to why does God allows suffering
make it your goal to deepen your
relationship with Christ this year and
subscribe to to video bible study on
YouTube to help you along your
[Music]
journey every day is an opportunity to
show kindness to the
[Music]
world every day is an opportunity to do
something that lets someone know you're
thinking of
them every day is an opportunity to give
without expecting anything in return
[Music]
every day is an opportunity to notice
someone in need and to go out of your
way to help
them every day is an
opportunity to do one small
thing to show someone you
care to make the world a better place
[Music]